smoking tires roaring engines and
lightning fast pit stops that's par for
the course at the 24-hour race staged at
Germany's famous Nurburgring track but
this year the teams also had to deal
with extreme weather conditions heat
torrential rain and hail pushed manna
machine to their limits the Matilda
racing team was in the thick of things
owner Michelle pots explains how the
team got it's unusual name when i'ma ova
tonight they were chatting over a beer
when his daughter Matilda was a year old
he couldn't think of anything clever and
teams all have racing in their names so
he thought let's use my daughter's name
and until the racing was born I think
from Matilda is now seven years old the
racing paddock has become her second
home
she likes watching the cars go around
the Matilda racing team works closely
with say OTT and helps with development
work during the 24 hour race a few saya
mechanics have come especially from
Spain to lend a hand it's transnational
teamwork
the coordination is very good so I think
there's a very good workout together the
experience from send sport and the wheel
to the world with Matilda is a good
combination then it's time to head for
the starting area for the 24 hour race
teams drivers and spectators flock here
to get a last look at the cars Matilda
has come to see your father
at exactly three thirty p.m. some 160
cars get off to a flying start they'll
tackle the infamous nordschleife a route
that's close to 25 kilometers long not
long afterwards hail and blinding rain
turned the racetrack into a slip and
slide one vehicle after another flies
off the track and into the barriers it's
the end of the 24-hour race for some and
it looks that way for one of Matilda's
racing seats to
an outreach driver andreas gordon says
after the shrine coydt's bent on rude to
arabic there's a corner on a little hill
top but on the hill where he should have
been able to see the racetrack again he
just saw a huge lake a river and it
caught him by surprise floss on danse
methodical devasting luckily for him the
race is halted for around three hours in
the meantime the mechanics are able to
repair enough of the damage to get the
car back in the race
right on schedule the crew once again
brings the fixed up seeit to the
starting line
even Mathilda helps however she can
when I saw the car Christ in the in that
corner heavily cries with one wheel
missing I said that's it we go home and
not even we raise that we didn't lose
any lab so only some positions that we
managed to get them in the first thing i
did so it was incredible experience in
spite of the awful weather the race
starts again in the early evening
Matilda and the pit crew look on as
their team race to catch up
unfortunately just one of the two
ciothes make it through the night the
other was taken out by another car
live our Klaus needs vez says they've
been hampered by accidents first by
heavy rains and hailstorms with the 201
and then his car the 202 got hit and is
beyond repair dr. Shelton atleast
medabot despite losing one of their cars
the race is thrilling right to the end
the remaining SIA with a starting number
201 even finishes first in its class
right until the final rounds the leaders
in the major vehicle classes battle it
out for the overall victory it's a
neck-and-neck race the victor in his
class Michele Potts is very pleased yeah
um does a vice versa mom he says they've
achieved their goal to show that a/c
oddly on TCR can handle the Nordschleife
life and be a contender in the 24-hour
race at the Nurburgring they're proud to
have crossed the finish line and won
their class everything's great autumn
teal a little one-man cottage Matilda
likes to learn things from her dad does
she plan to follow in his footsteps one
day she doesn't know yet but she might
become a race car driver till then
she'll keep cheering her father on from
the pits